[Applause]
this is roman abramovich russian
billionaire and owner of premier league
football club chelsea
he's handed over control of the club and
now has a new goal
he's accepted ukraine's requests to
negotiate with russia to end the war
abramovic has remained tight-lipped
about his stance unlike some billionaire
businessman once close to russian
president vladimir putin now openly
criticizing his decision to wage war
oleg durepuska he's known for throwing
lavish parties at davos
and making a fortune from energy and
aluminium
he's been sanctioned by the u.s since
2018 for his close ties to putin
on telegram he called for peace and
negotiations
is causing deep unease among russia's
elites
those who depend on access to the global
financial system and these people are
the sustainers and enablers and
supporters of the putin regime so on
this as on every other political front
uh since the beginning of this
unnecessary war putin finds himself
worse off not better off
one of russia's richest men mikhail
friedman called for an end to the
bloodshed in a letter to his
london-based private equity firm
and ukrainian-born businessman dimitro
fiertas is also opposing the war
he'd previously funneled money into
ukraine's campaigns of pro-russian
politicians
the bloomberg billionaires index shows
within 24 hours of the start of war 22
of russia's richest people saw 39
billion net worth wiped out
and it's not just oligarchs speaking out
russian businessman oleg tinkov is the
founder of one of the world's largest
online banks but has no political ties
to the kremlin
he says innocent people are dying in
ukraine and that he's against the war
but opinion is divided on whether this
will make an impact
businessmen who have already spoken
quite openly
about a peace about the need to somehow
somehow change and end this conflict but
i don't think that it will have a direct
impact on the russian foreign policy
most of russia's political elite has
stood firm with the president
but will those who broke rank put
pressure on putin and will others follow
laura berdamani al jazeera